money Kelly is with us from Kalamazoo
Michigan hi Kelly how are you I'm better
than I deserve how are you gay just the
same
what's up I don't question we had a
brand new college student and my
question is around how to help him
budget to help him feel responsible for
his college education with the money
that he's earning knowing that he can't
pay for it all okay I'm a little bit
confused
the money that he's earning he's he's
developed a good work ethic and we've
always followed the principle that when
the kids making money or they get their
Commission that 70% of spend and then in
20 and a 10% fill in to save and share
and she doesn't he doesn't make enough
money to pay for his college education
we have the money to do that but we
don't want to just freely write check
and so I'm wondering one we want him to
be invested in his education okay um
does that require money why can he not
be emotionally invested in his education
cuz it sounds like this is a good kid it
doesn't sound like you got a trouble it
get here well he is a good kid and I'll
tell you what was disappointing to us is
that he worked hard all summer and when
we and we should have been watching more
closely but it really looks like he
spent most of what he was making on
coffee and fast food and he wasn't
putting much money in his savings
account so what was he was did you have
the expectation that he was going to pay
for fall we had an expectation he was
going to contribute and maybe that's
where we made them escape it is on you
then because you didn't manager you
didn't manage a senior in high schools
thing here where you said okay you need
this much money and that means you need
to be putting us at this much a week and
I'm going to look and verify that you
are doing that okay because he did what
every high school say
you would do coffee and fast food um so
you know if you have an expectation that
he now your reason for him paying for it
is just that you want him invested
though not because you need him to do
that financially we really don't but I
really masculine is that there's a
spectrum on paying for college okay all
the way to I know one guy who's wealthy
and he won't pay a dime of his kids
college he said they're going to figure
it out they can go get loans they can
they can work they can do whatever but
I'm not paying for it and I've told him
that since there were three get over it
he's really wealthy he can do it he just
that's one end of the spectrum the other
end of the spectrum is the end that that
we were on and that was we saved up and
had the money and we paid cash for their
college and gave them a monthly stipend
to exist on there was not a lot but it
was a reasonable amount the kids always
claimed it was about half of what they
needed so they had to work some to get
some spending money but but they were
invested just not financially invested
in college they had proven their ability
to save and give with buying their first
car that kind of stuff we taught that
lesson there we did not teach it at
college and yet every one of them
because we work together to manage
schedules and expectations and so forth
you're going to behave in a way that's
consistent with our value system or
we're not paying for it and that
includes getting good grades and that
includes being on a four-year schedule
because after four years I'm paying for
nothing and all three graduated in four
years and all three graduated with
reasonably good grades one of them magna
Kumar something or other but um hey you
know so you know that's the other end
from my buddy who makes them pay for
everything
you're kind of in the middle between
those two ends right and the way you're
going at it and so none of the three are
wrong it's just you've got to clearly
communicate what's going on there and
ask yourself why are you doing that in
my buddies case you know he argues with
me all the time that I spoiled my kids
and my kids performance in the
marketplace indicates anything except
spoiled they're all three very
hardworking and very diligent and so
apparently I didn't spoil them but
he says well they would have they would
have been a lot tougher they would have
been a lot better off if you don't made
them work their way through yeah maybe
that's probably true I work my way
through so um it doesn't kill you you
know my husband and I both had ourselves
through college you were both really
proud of that
so I think that especially for my
husband it's hard to think about just
paying for a kid to go to college and
just writing the checks without him
contributing so if they have a mentality
an entitlement mentality or if they're
not performing and they're not living
their life according to our value system
boom I'm right there instantaneously I'm
right there but I think you know I feel
like my kids in defense of this position
not to argue but there's two ways of
looking at it and I think both are right
either ones okay with me but in defense
I think the kids obviously were
emotionally and spiritually invested in
the process because they perform if they
had not been invested in the process
they would not have gotten out in four
years with good grades and lived a you
know not perfect but a clean a clean
life I got to and so that that's what
you're looking for so as far as if you
want them to invest you need to tell
them how much and when and help them
develop some reasonable goals and
expectations
don't just let them wander along and
then can't figure out why high school
senior spent all his money on fast food
that's on you guys so but next next
semester if you want him to work and he
needs to have 300 dollars to put in or
five hundred dollars or two thousand
dollars or whatever number you come up
with you communicate that and indicate
that and show them how to get enough
hours and you know help them set the
goals and develop realistic ways of
reaching those goals and then you're
right by god they'll be invested and I
don't have a problem with that by the
way let me say one more time I don't
think your husband is wrong I don't
think that at all but also don't think I
we're wrong on the other side so I think
it's just a different approach to the
same subject what I do think is wrong is
to just you know write checks for kids
who are misbehaving or kids who won't go
to class or kids who have an entitlement
bratty mentality or stuff like that I'm
not I'm not going to suggest you put
money behind that kind of thing but
neither you nor
we're facing that in our situations so
hey great question thanks for joining us
you